yellow welcome to this little
announcement video but we've got a good
reason for that are you probably read it
already I'm going to play a match this
saturday from release of this video that
we tomorrow saturday seventh and it will
be a match of a couple of games against
I am John Bartholomew yeah you also know
him as Finn's maybe yeah he also has got
a very popular YouTube channel and we'll
be doing a yea dual stream so to say we
both will be streaming this match and it
will be a blitz chance fire plus 2 also
3 + 2 + 1 + 1 bullet so we've got three
different time controls there and you
see the details in the little box that
the video has yeah it will be at 10pm
center loop in time on saturday or this
would make it form in the afternoon US
East Coast time the same time as I'm
usually doing my monday broadcasts yeah
we'll be playing on the ICC and you can
also watch there but make sure to watch
on Twitch yeah it's twitch.tv just
explained without the e via because yeah
you know without thee you can also watch
on John John sir stream of course I
think it's on YouTube yeah he also has
got a video out and we both will be also
showing the archived and show later on
YouTube yeah so make sure to join this
Saturday will be lots of fun thanks guys